good morning kick it's Tuesday I'm not
sure if I've previously mentioned this
but I've been reading a lot about
tuberculosis lately like I've read many
Journal articles and over 20 books and
today I want to highlight for you my
favorite tuberculosis reads thus far so
when I talk about TV people get most
excited about the historical stuff like
the fact that TB gave us the cowboy hat
and the stethoscope and Pasadena
California and I do get why that stuff
is fascinating but I want to begin with
a contemporary first person account of
tuberculosis published by a small press
in 2020 because it reminds us that TB is
not exclusively or even primarily
historical stigmatized by Honda and
mglon is a wonderful Memoir about a
young woman growing up in an
impoverished community in Mongolia sorry
I have to keep moving because the light
is moving So eventually Honda is
diagnosed with tuberculosis which begins
a completely different life from the one
she thought she was going to have a life
of dehumanization and stigmatization
it's just a beautiful book and it's not
a spoiler going to say that eventually
the author gets a master's degree from
New York University the whole story is
just astonishing I loved it secondly I
learned so much amazing history like how
Arthur Conan Doyle participated in TB
research and how TB affected our ideas
of vampires and so much more from
Phantom plague by Vidya Krishnan it's
probably my overall favorite history of
TB because it's approachable and
readable but at the same time very
rigorously researched and then in the
final section of phantom plague Krishnan
tells the story of Shreya tripathi a
teenager who was diagnosed with
multi-drug resistant tuberculosis and
had to sue her government in order to
access treatment she eventually won the
lawsuit but it took so long to wind its
way through the courts that the
treatment arrived too late for her and
she died of tuberculosis at the age of
19. I recently learned that Trey was
actually a big fan of my book The Fault
in Our Stars and reread it toward the
end of her life and I just so wish I
could have met her because she's become
one of my heroes and I'm really great
thankful to Phantom plague for telling
her story okay the last TB writing I
want to recommend is a paper written by
another one of my heroes Dr Paul Farmer
called social scientists and the new
tuberculosis in this article he argues
that we really can't separate
tuberculosis from the social conditions
like poverty and malnutrition and
overcrowded housing that lead to
tuberculosis and he tells the story of a
Haitian teenager named Robert David who
was diagnosed with tuberculosis and had
to take a daily walk to be able to
access his medications but they didn't
have all the right medications at that
clinic so he eventually developed drug
resistance and over the course of the
next nine years continued to seek
treatment every way he could but the
system just couldn't support him and so
like Shreya he died of tuberculosis but
did he really die of tuberculosis or did
he die from poverty and systems that
simply do not act as if all human lives
are equally valuable it's a brilliant
paper and I highly recommend you read it
but I can't tell you exactly how to read
it because the world of academic
publishing is so fully labyrinthine that
I couldn't figure out a way to access
this paper without paying 42 dollars
which is a little absurd so it may be
somebody in comments will be able to
help so just to State the obvious Hank
uh we tend to solve the problems that we
devote resources to like between 1950
and 1961 many drugs were synthesized
that could effectively treat
tuberculosis and then between 1961 which
is around the time the TV stopped being
a big problem in rich countries and 2012
no drugs were developed that can treat
tuberculosis and so my last
recommendation is to vote with global
Health in mind to work to increase
awareness of this profound Injustice and
to donate if you can to Partners in
Health or other organizations that are
working to make TB what it should be
history Hank I'll see you on Friday